Speaker 1: a former Newsmax host and right
wing shock jock, as they're calling him by
the name of Dick Ferrell, died of covid.
Now, Ferrell had spent a lot of time during
the pandemic trashing Dr. Fauci, calling the
entire pandemic a scam.
DIMMICK and essentially trying to downplay
everything, downplay the effectiveness of
the vaccines, casting doubt on those, casting
doubt on the pandemic itself, saying, oh,
this is Democrats trying to control things
dies last week from covid, but before he died.
He had one of those come to Jesus moments
that we have seen far too often in the people
who die from the fact excuse me, die from
the virus.
He texted his friends.
Telling them, go get the vaccine.
So here was somebody who had devoted more
than a year.
Of his media career.
To try to convince people that this wasn't
real, that this wasn't a big deal, that it
was all a scam.
And the last thing he did on this earth.
Was tell his closest friends it's real.
Protect yourselves, get the vaccine.
Now he's dead.
We also had the story last week of Scott Apley
from Texas, Republican official on a county
board from Texas.
He died of covid, he died of covid five days.
After posting anti vax material on Facebook.
Left behind a young, I believe, infant son.
Left behind a wife.
Dead from covid.
These stories.
Of people dying from covid after spending
a year and a half pretending it didn't exist
are becoming far too common.
We are now at the point we're getting at least
one per day.
And a lot of them all in the same way before
the person dies, they're tweeting out, they're
texting out there, doing whatever they can,
they're calling the loved ones and saying,
please get the vaccine.
I can't believe I didn't do this, I was too
stupid, some of them have said.
And that really is what we're looking at here,
folks.
I'm willing to bet I would never have agreed
with anything Dick Farrell ever said, ever
in his political career.
And I still wish that that man were alive
today.
Same thing with Mr. Scott Apley, same thing
with all of these people that are dying because
they didn't want to do the one thing that
probably would have saved their lives.
Every death is a tragedy, doesn't matter if
it's on the right or on the left, if it's
an anti Voxer or if it's a you know, whoever
every death is a tragedy.
And it's unnecessary at this point to stories
like this are hard stories like this are getting
very, very hard to report on.
But I do want to continue to do this because
hopefully they get through to some people.
Hopefully this acts as the wake up call when
you hear these stories of people gasping in
their final breaths saying, I wish I'd gotten
the vaccine, asking their doctors, can I still
get it?
And the doctor having to tearfully tell them,
I'm sorry, but it's too late.
That's the country we're living in now, and
that's a country that has been consumed with
misinformation.
I'm Fern Cousins in for David Pakman, we'll
be right back.